hello sir I'm Zika virus ooh from tagged
Roger College of Engineering madura
india i would like to ask q's and two
questions my first question is that
there are currently there are two
prevailing theories for the evolution of
universe first one is the Big Crunch and
second or in a big freeze I would like
to suggest a third one that is do you
think whether the existence of wormholes
may create a new dimension for the
evolution of universe since it prevents
the collapse of the universe while it
takes the way it continues to contract
forming a maze of wormholes do you think
it is possible and my second question is
that in conventional computing we have
modern micro process to process bits so
what what would the quantum computing
processors would possibly look like